Hello, welcome to your unsolicited walkthrough of bash.tv presented by me, Richard.
Alright, let's begin. So here we have the beautiful landing page of bash.tv,
where you will find a feed right in the center and you can look at all the projects that everyone's
building. Look at that, PlayStation Modeling Tool. You can also filter by most popular,
and also the ones that you created yourself. On the top left, you're going to see chats,
which is just a chat that you can join and chat with your friends. For the hackathon,
we're going to be using this one right here. And below that, you're just going to see a recent
feed of projects that you've opened. Now on the top right, you're going to have your profile,
and let's take a look at mine. When creating one, you'll be able to change your display name,
and also link out to a website. You can even change your username, color here, and add a creator emoji.
But how do we create space for build? Okay, okay, settle down, settle down, I got you.
All you have to do is just hit the screen button over here that says create. You can name your space.
Let's use an emoji for the space. And for permissions, this is where you can designate
who's allowed to interact with the agent. So this is what it looks like when you create a space.
And you can see over here, it says let's get started, launch with 500 credits. So if you look
over here, you're going to see 1.1,000 credits. This is my personal balance. And for every new
project that you start, you'll have to add in 500 credits. So let's begin. All right, over here,
you're going to see the 500 credits that we added in. The cool thing is that every single person
that you add into this space is able to boost the project itself. If you click the settings icon
over here, it's going to open this menu where you can change the detail level of the messages
that you receive from the agent, you can add your own skills, you can change permissions,
you can check out the history, and also look at the metrics. Down here on the lower left,
you're going to see your prompt box for the agent. You're going to see an attached file icon where
you can attach files. You're going to see the emojis and the model selector, where you will
currently find 264 models to build whatever your mind can think of. Now, if you're completely
new to vibe coding, every time you prompt the agent, it's going to spend some of your credit.
The amount of credit that gets used depends on the model that you have selected. I know a lot
of you're going to want to go with opus for some of your prompts. Just keep an eye on your credit
balance because opus will use a lot of credit. Over here on the right side, you're going to see
it's as humans. This is where you and all your friends can chat as you build together. You can
say things like hello, hi, how are you? Well, I guess there's only one thing left to do. We need
a bathroom. What do I want to build today? Alright, so I'm having it build me a 3D game set in a zoo
enclosure where players are able to get their picture taken and the game then turns them into
animals that inhabit the space. Time to pass. The cool thing while the agent is thinking,
you can just be here chatting with your friends about the next steps and other things that they
should be building. And also, if someone gets another idea, they can just type it in here and
their prompt enters a queue. And look at that, it finished. Alright, let's check it out. Let's see,
let's see. Okay, we can move around, noise. We can also drag our mouse to spin the camera around.
Alright, I guess it's time to join the zoo, huh? Oh god, here we go.
Richard. Snap and release. Oh, am I here? Hello? Where is that me?
What am I? Some kind of frog? A beetle? A bear. I'm a bear. Alright, so yeah,
That's how you build with bash. I will see you guys at the hackathon. Bye-bye!